khloe kardashian is sharing a cryptic
message about healing just days after
her ex tristan thompson's paternity
scandal played out on her family's
reality show i find out what tristan is
doing with the rest of the world a
courtesy would be not doing it but fine
if you do it you're not even going to
give me a heads up for the rest of the
world
it's just an additional slap in my face
chloe posted this quote she says she saw
on twitter that's the thing about
healing you heal into someone else
a completely new person not even because
you want to but because who you were
could no longer survive as let it go and
let a new you happen i think it's
important to show people you can turn
your life around you can go through hell
and high water but you can still come
out and have a beautiful positive happy
life yes preach it coco but the big
question is is this message directly
related to the drama that went down with
tristan you'll recall the nba star
admitted to fathering a child with
fitness model marlene nichols while he
was together with chloe did tristan have
every opportunity to tell me yes was
tristan going to tell me if there wasn't
a baby involved absolutely not and that
shows a lot about his character the
entire thing is despicable during her
appearance on the not skinny but not fat
podcast last month chloe who's no
stranger to posting these inspirational
quotes said fans shouldn't take them too
seriously it's always for myself like i
might be drawn to a quote i see and it
might pertain to what i'm going through
a lot of the times it's not i just think
it's beautiful or i think someone should
see this
and i mean i guess coincidentally maybe
something's happening in my life that it
could pertain to but they might make it
about
a family member or
just anything that might be news related
and i'm like that had nothing to do with
that yeah so it may just be coco simply
hinting she's on her path of healing
exactly but amid her healing chloe is
still shutting down rumors about her
dating life isn't that crazy over the
weekend she responded to a kardashian
fan account that shared an anonymous
post claiming the good american founder
is dating another nba player but khloe
set the record straight writing i am not
seeing a soul i am happy focusing on my
daughter and myself for a while my
secret is just i think having a positive
outlook on life as for what's next with
coco's love life well during the
kardashians season finale she revealed
that she wants what her sister kim's
found with boyfriend pete davidson pete
is so sweet i don't know him really
really well but from what i do know i
think it's
really drama free it's really easy
and i think that's something that's the
end goal everyone wants that fairy tale
everyone wants the happily ever after i
think that's the hope
love shouldn't be this hard here's to
hoping coco finds her perfect match
[Music]
you